laurent fabius georgina dufoix edmond
hervé renvoyé devant la cour de justice
pour homicides involontaires dans
l'affairé du sang contaminé
le médecin de festina et rich rieker té
le directeur sportif bruno roussel
viennent d'être mises en examen et
écrouées et les deux hommes
reconnaissent le dopage de certains
coureurs
la fermeture annoncée des magasins crazy
djordje dont la formule et la vente
location à destination des plus
défavorisés un concept largement
critiqué le repentir de la nation russe
lors de l'enterrement du tsar nicolas ii
à saint pétersbourg une cérémonie
boycottée par le patriarche de l'église
orthodoxe 14e édition des francofolies
avec en direct dans ce journal bernard
lavilliers à quelques minutes de son
entrée en scène voilà monsieur bonsoir
dans l' affaire du sang contaminé je
vous le dise en titre laurent fabius
georgina dufoix edmond hervé sont
renvoyés devant la cour de justice de la
république pour complicité
d'empoisonnement au terme d'un long
feuilleton judiciaire sur laquelle nous
reviendrons dans un instant cette
décision très attendue n'a donc pas
suivi le réquisitoire du procureur qui
demandait un non-lieu dominique
verdeilhan françois granier unis dans le
même combat
le président de l'association des
hémophiles et le président de
l'association des transfusés tous deux
attendent empoisonnement non lieu ou un
homicide involontaire à 17 heures un
bref communiqué élus sur le pas de la
porte de la cour de justice et ordonné
le renvoi devant la formation de
jugement d'être des trois anciens
membres du gouvernement vise en examen
pour homicides involontaires et
atteintes involontaires à l'intégrité
des personnes
voilà plus de cinquante sommes amassées
dans la petite salle d'audience des
documents des procès verbaux des
expertises
après quatre ans d'instruction les trois
magistrats ont choisi la solution
médiane homicide involontaire un délit
puni par deux ans d'emprisonnement les
avocats de la défense parle d'une
décision sous pression on est même allé
jusqu'à demander la récusation des trois
magistrats instructeurs viennent de
rendre cette décision alors qu'il était
en train de délibérer
s'il ne s'agit pas là d'une pression sur
des magistrats alors
sur le point de prendre leurs décisions
alors les mots n'ont plus de sens on n'a
pas le courage d'affronter les victimes
mais il faut reconnaître qu'il ya des
victimes et georgina dufoix a toujours
dit ça commisération et ses sentiments
pour les victimes
donc je pense qu'on a effectivement
voulu chercher une éventuelle
culpabilité en laissant le soin à
l'accord justice de la république dans
sa composition différente de prendre la
décision finale
une demi-satisfaction pour les victimes
un non-lieu aurait fermé définitivement
le volet politique du dossier
un procès est aujourd'hui possible c'est
une demi-satisfaction comme vous dites
mais surtout ce qui est important c'est
qu'il y aura un jugement dès qu'on croit
décortiquer ce qui s'est passé ce qui
est important de cas pour les hémophiles
c'est non pas la vengeance mais savoir
dans le détail et publiquement ce qui
s'est passé au sein du gouvernement
les anciens ministres se sont donné
quelques heures de réflexion pour
décider de se pourvoir ou non en
cassation
c'est donc après une procédure
judiciaire riche de rebondissements que
laurent fabius ancien premier ministre
georgina dufoix ancien secrétaire d'état
aux affaires sociales et à douai hervé
ancien secrétaire d'état à la santé
seront jugés devant la cour de justice
la mise en cause de ses trois ministres
socialistes démarre à l'automne 92
une affaire qui prendra immédiatement un
tour politique françoise valais et
thierry kurt et les faits remontent à
mai 83 où l'on apprend que le virus du
sida est transmissible par le sang
si certains pays prennent des
dispositions la france tarde à réagir
les collectes dans les prisons lieu à
haut risque continue jusqu'en 86 ans 84
on sait que chauffer les produits
inactive les virus cette technique n'est
pas utilisé en france avril 85 un test
de dépistage des donneurs existe
la france attendra août 85 pour le
rendre obligatoire
résultat les produits contaminés
circulent premières victimes les
hémophiles et les transfusés en 88
arrivent les premières plaintes contre
le centre national de transfusion
sanguine seul fournisseur des produits
en 92
michel garretta directeur du cnts et
condamné à quatre ans de prison
les familles des victimes sont révoltés
ces mêmes familles dénoncent l'absence
de hauts responsables dans le box des
accusés et se retourne contre les
ministres laurent fabius premier
ministre de l'époque
edmond hervé secrétaire d'état à la
santé et georgina dufoix ministre des
affaires sociales
en 94 ses trois ministres sont
poursuivis pour complicité
d'empoisonnement un crime passible de la
réclusion à perpétuité
parallèlement se poursuit une
instruction visant les médecins et les
membres des cabinets ministériels
à ce jour trente et une personnes ou
d'été nous voyons maintenant les
réactions laurent fabius par voie de
communiqué souligne que cette décision
écarte la qualification de complicité
d'empoisonnement
l'ancien premier ministre ajoute sous
réserve d'éventuels recours c'est donc
devant la cour de justice que j'établis
rec en conscience j'ai agi ainsi que je
l' ai toujours indiquée comme je le
devais et aussi vite que possible
en ce moment je pense avec compassion
victimes de ce drame sur le fond je
reste convaincu qu'à l'issue de la
procédure la vérité et la justice
finiront par l'emporter
quant à edmond hervé ils contestent
cette décision de renvoi qui s'opposent
aux conclusions de non lieu prises par
le procureur général edmond hervé qui se
dit stupéfait que la commission
d'instruction n'est même pas cru devoir
communiquer rendre public les motifs de
cette décision
fin de citation ainsi donc pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république trois ministres dont l'actuel
président de l'assemblée nationale vont
comparaître devant la cour de justice
une décision judiciaire hautement
politique ou une première décision
spectaculaire le renvoi des trois
ministres pour empoisonnement semblait
improbable au regard de la définition
récente de la cour de cassation mais les
juges ont détourné le problème juridique
alors aujourd'hui à l'horizon de landes
1001 procès du volet politique de la
sphère est envisageable et sur le banc
des prévenus figurent l'actuel président
de l'assemblée nationale ce renvoi de
laurent fabius va probablement engendrer
dans les jours prochains des
commentaires plus politique que
juridique la décision de la cour de
justice provoque un double malaise
d'abord on ne connaît pas ce soir les
motivations qui ont amené les juges à
décider de se renvoient ensuite et bien
en quatre ans les juges sont passés de
la non-assistance à personne en danger à
l'homicide involontaire en passant par
l'empoisonnement
d'où le sentiment d'une justice à
géométrie variable
alors l'autre volet de ce dossier
concerne les médecins dont par exemple
le docteur garetta quelle incidence ce
jugement rassure le le cours de l'or à
faire écouter séparent dos et qui est
toujours à l'instruction mais l'on voit
mal comment les médecins et les membres
des cabinets ministériels également
poursuivi pour complicité
d'empoisonnement seraient traités
différemment des politiques mais surtout
le renvoi des trois ministres ce soir
créer un précédent pour d'autres
dossiers à l'instruction
l'hormone de croissance la vache folle
et le dossier de l'amiante pour les
victimes
c'est peut-être la fin d'une période
résumé par une formule trop célèbre
responsable mais pas coupable
merci dominique verdeilhan l' affaire
festina avec il ya moins d'une heure la
mise en examen et l'incarcération de
bruno roussel le directeur sportif de
festina et du médecin de l'équipe éric
ryckaert nous rejoignons tout de suite
en direct pascal douce est bon quelles
sont les informations que vous avez pu
obtenir ces derniers instants les
dernières informations sont un coup de
théâtre à la fin de leur garde à vue
bruno roussel et eric ryckaert le
médecin de l'équipe festina aurait
reconnu le dopage de leurs coureurs un
dopage précise-t-il sous contrôle
médical
à eux d'en dire plus la semaine
prochaine au juge d'instruction qui
devra les confronter à willy voet willy
voet c'est le soigneur de l'équipe
festina
c'est lui qui a été arrêté la semaine
dernière en possession de produits
dopants en particulier de le paix au le
fameux epo
ce délai a été accordé aux avocats en
fait qui voudraient tous autant qu'ils
sont prendre connaissance du dossier
merci pour ces informations est
peut-être nous vous retrouverons en
cours de ce journal rompant la loi du
silence je vous propose maintenant
d'écouter le témoignage des reventes
mater our cycliste professionnel qui a
été contrôlé positif en mars dernier
pour ce jeune sportif devenu aujourd'hui
cascadeur les coureurs sont les dindons
de la farce c'est eux qui paient le prix
le dopage une pratique courante entre
les mains de médecins marron olivier
caroff eric de l'agneau ma première
année professionnelle c'est la
plaisanterie ce que je prenais j'étais
largué tout le temps le jour où j'ai où
j'ai fait comme les autres
j'étais au niveau des doses 2 p o erwann
menthéour ne cache pas s'en être servi
cycliste professionnel pendant trois ans
il a mis fin à sa carrière en septembre
dernier après une chute lors d'une
compétition internationale
il portait le maillot jaune le dopage
c'est complètement désacraliser dans le
milieu sportif professionnel
on est complètement déculpabiliser ça
fait partie du métier et yves
déculpabilise qu'est-ce qui vous
déculpabilise c7 c'est une éducation on
est tenus on est tenu à être tout le
temps au top vous marchez pas pendant
trois mois on va commencer à vous poser
des questions vous mettre une petite
lettre pour vous marchez pas attention
vous trois lettres on peut se faire
licencier
erwan a marché lui et fort au point de
devenir un espoir du cyclisme français
au point aussi de perdre toute illusion
sur l'univers dans lequel ils évoluent
et c'est un peu les jeux du cirque
on est des gladiateurs
c'est simple le dopage aujourd'hui c'est
un et dopage série le tournant demande
d'une marche pour arriver au même
résultat
on prend on prend cette règle a pour
kippour pour le spectacle pour aller
plus vite
qui est responsable l'ancien coureur dit
n'avoir jamais été forcé de se doper
il a simplement accepté une loi non
écrite dont il assure qu'elle est
commune à plusieurs sports de haut
niveau
pour lui l'équipe festina et ses
responsables risquent de servir de bouc
émissaire à tout un système
on sait pas seulement le vélo c'est pas
c'est tous les sports professionnels
il faut arrêter de concentrer sa sur
bruno roussel ceux qui disent ça bah qui
se regardent dans une glace ce qui le
laisse tomber lâchement aujourd'hui et
pour willy vu de pareil on va on va
câble et oui les voûtes me dégoûte c'est
un père tranquille
un père de famille un soigneur qui
aiment le vélo qui aiment le court un
père de famille lui aussi erwann
menthéour est aujourd'hui cascadeur dans
l'équipe de rémy julienne un risque
calculé
et puis en marge de cette affaire de
dopage on a appris aujourd'hui le
veulent de nombreux flacons au chu de
poitiers à un préparateur en pharmacie
seraient à l'origine d'une partie de ses
vols à répétition qui concerne au total
une centaine de flacco 2 p o
à l'évidence les développements
judiciaires de l' affaire festina
assombrissent le tour de france les
coureurs espère que l'esprit du sport
reprendra ses droits
mais en attendant il se sert les coudes
florent gautreau alain poirier un bon
bain de foule
voilà comment richard virenque prend des
forces chaque matin rien de tel que le
soutien populaire pour oublier les
déboires judiciaires à la châtre comme
ailleurs les amoureux des festina sont
nombreux et ils sont fidèles
mais quoi en souriant non parce que si
je suis le son durant ce pouvoir bien
que s'il est pas là je parte il
rassurez vous madame d'iran qui est
toujours là les coureurs serre les
coudes rassuré par le message de miguel
rodriguez le patron de festina un
soutien capital pour une équipe au bord
de la crise de nerfs elle est forte mais
jusqu'à quand parce que tout ça nous
tombe dessus et pour l'instant on
résiste on résiste peut-être ça va nous
lâcher avant la fin du toursky il fait
normal parce que on dort pas la nuit ont
fait des rêves virenque parle de rêve ne
dit plus cauchemar
l'équipe festina est plus que jamais
dans la course on évoque à nouveau les
chances de ses coureurs et les
organisateurs du tour soutiennent
toujours
l'équipe andorrane le spectateur du tour
de france et il y en a des millions se
tient les coudes et se resserre autour
des gens qui sont aujourd'hui sous les
feux de la rampe
paradoxalement c'est donc en course que
les coureurs retrouve un peu de calme
le premier des festina n'a terminé que
25e aujourd'hui peu importe la course
reprend ses droits et virenque retrouve
le sourire
jamais trop perdre et mais bon quand on
laisse tranquille 1
le moral est au beau fixe et pour cette
sixième étape aujourd'hui c'est
l'italien mario cipollini qui a remporté
au sprint sa deuxième victoire en deux
jours après châteauroux cipollini a
devancé cet après-midi abri
l'italien nicola meena lee et le tchèque
svoboda le français quant à guy
frédéricq manquer ça est arrivé
quatrième au terme des 204 km le strania
o'grady conserve le maillot jaune de
leader il a été félicité par bernadette
chirac se présente à l'arrivée de cette
6e étape
aux pays bas la police enquête sur un
réseau de pédophilie sur internet dont
les ramifications pourrait toucher la
belgique et peut-être même l'allemagne
des milliers de photos pornographiques
sans passer au crible alors qu'une ligne
téléphonique spéciale devrait recueillir
d'éventuels témoignages vincent nguyen
les photos anodine des premiers pas d'un
bébé non l'horreur d'un réseau pédophile
sur internet de cette iconographie
numérique on ne verra que quelques
clichés aux dires mêmes des enquêteurs
hollandais qui l'ont découvert le reste
est abominable
je suis très choqué cet enfant n'a que
12 à 18 mois
c'est vraiment choquant et cela concerne
bien d'autres ces images proviennent de
chez cet homme guérite oulrich était
gérant d'un magasin d'informatique il a
été assassiné le mois dernier en italie
à son domicile des cambrioleurs se sont
emparés de son matériel informatique
mais la police néerlandaise n'a pas
tardé à mettre la main sur ces
disquettes les clichés pédophiles
qu'elles contiennent étaient destinés à
la vente ou à internet
marcel faire flow sommes en est
convaincu il dirige une association
belge de lutte contre la pédophilie est
lui aussi a pu se procurer du matériel
appartenant à ulrich ces images étaient
diffusées sur le net
l'homme qui avait laissé 10 qui est un
spécialiste
autrement il n'aurait pas pu constituer
de quelles archives l'association est
persuadé que le réseau existe depuis
longtemps et il a des ramifications dans
de nombreux pays
la police néerlandaise ne confirme pas
cette hypothèse pour le moment mais elle
entretient d'ores et déjà des contacts
intensifs avec l'allemagne et la
belgique où d'autres enquêtes sont en
cours en france les magasins président
georges verts il ya un peu moins de deux
ans et dont le concept et la location
vente à bas prix à destination des plus
défavorisés une formule très critique à
l'époque
eh bien ces deux magasins vont fermer à
la rentrée si on a décidé
le groupe britannique thorn à l'origine
de cette formule dont le risque selon
ses détracteurs et d'exploiter la
pauvreté sébastien guibert jean-paul
chaussée ce n'était pas vraiment la
bousculade aujourd'hui dans le magasin
crédit georges de bobigny et ça ne
s'arrangera pas l'enseigne fermera
définitivement à la mi septembre
c'est pas contente parce que vraiment
s'arranger petites gens qui ne peuvent
pas faire de crédit et ça ça coûte un
peu plus cher mais on est d'accord ça
arrange vraiment les familles sinon pas
de on peut partir je ne peux pas car de
févier et surtout les retraités
je vais même qu'il prendre un crédit
chez 2 mai avec m'a rappelé je me suis
rendu compte que le produit ou à devenir
trois fois plus cher président georges
s'est installé ici dans ce centre
commercial en novembre 96 avec une idée
choc permettre aux foyers à revenus
modestes de s'acheter pour quelques
dizaines de francs par semaine pendant
trois ans maximum
une télévision un canapé ou une chaîne
hi fi un objet qui revient au bout du
compte au moins deux fois plus cher que
le prix coûtant commercialement ça
marchait très bien les clients sont là
les contrats sont va bien pour
satisfaire et ont été effectivement un
petit peu surpris de la décision du
groupe japonais qui arracherait
le groupe formé en fait d'arrêter les
magasins président georges en france
officiellement donc il ne s'agirait que
d'une réorganisation financière du
nouveau propriétaire de la chaîne
britannique
mais pour les associations de
consommateurs la formule gagnante en
angleterre est vouée à l'échec en france
nous en france nous avons des salaires
qui sont mensuelles et quittons pas être
de mater les prestations familiales est
une fois le mois elles ne tombent pas
toutes les semaines et je crois que ça
c'est important de pouvoir gérer sur un
mois son budget
les clients de crazy georges eux se
verront proposer d'acheter
définitivement leurs produits à prix
réduits
les négociations sur les 35 heures avec
pierre la difficile rencontre entre
patronat et syndicats de la métallurgie
un secteur clef qui emploie près de 2
millions de salariés ces discussions
illustre les résistances du patronat les
discussions ont tourné court réunion de
la dernière chance jeudi prochain en
revanche sur le terrain les 35 heures se
font au coup par coup notamment dans ce
secteur de la métallurgie apparemment si
réticents l'exemple de cette entreprise
près de châlons sur marne où un accord
vient d'être signé dominique barrouche
alain locascio 13 heures c'est la relève
ici au bronze industriel
on travaille déjà en trois huit mais 24
heures sur 24 ce n'est pas encore assez
au vu des carnets de commandes qui
explose
d'où la décision en mettant en place une
quatrième équipe de passer aux 35 heures
le pdg s'en félicite mais reconnaît que
cette solution n'est pas applicable
partout pour nous et ça répond à des
des conditions qui nous sont spécifiques
nous avons besoin d'augmenter notre
production parce que nous augmentons nos
parts de marché en particulier à
l'exportation ce que tout le monde ne
peut pas forcément faire on est bien
revenu des années noires celles des
années 70 dépôt de bilan effectif amputé
des deux tiers depuis de gros
investissements ont permis de se
spécialiser dans des alliages utilisés
par airbus ou la fusée ariane reste est
à réembaucher
une aubaine les 35 heures en organisant
le travail le samedi
elles permettent de mieux rentabiliser
les machines avec un coup de pouce
financier de l'état
là on va se faire remplacer
pourquoi ils occasionnent l'optimisme
syndicale n'a pas été partagée par tous
les salariés
ils ont beau avoir obtenu les 35 heures
sans perte de salaire ils le paieront
par des pauses plus courtes et surtout
le travail le samedi il a fallu
convaincre les négociations ont mis six
mois pour aboutir au lendemain de la
déclaration surprise de charles pasqua
demandant la régularisation de tous les
sans papiers la réponse de la fermeté de
jean pierre chevènement qui rappelle que
les demandeurs non régularisées auront
vocation à retourner dans leur pays
fin de citation ce sondage politique où
l'on retrouve les faits mondial avec les
cotes de popularité de jacques chirac et
de lionel jospin largement à la hausse
65% des personnes interrogées jugent
l'action du chef de l'état plutôt
positive
70 % pour le premier ministre selon le
baromètre louis harris politique
et puis on a appris aujourd'hui le
suicide de roger quilliot âgé de 73 ans
l'ancien maire socialiste de clermont
ferrand a choisi de mettre fin à ses
jours
souffrant depuis des années son épouse a
voulu l'accompagner dans l'âme
or mais était sauvé ils savent ils ne
seraient plus en danger le couple avait
adressé des lettres leurs proches ont
expliqué leur décision
les obsèques de roger quilliot qui fut
notamment ministre du logement de 81 83
auront lieu lundi à l'étranger le
repentir de la nation russe lors de la
messe d'enterrement à saint pétersbourg
de nicolas 2 81 ans jour pour jour après
l'exécution du dernier tsar et de sa
famille par les bolchéviques une
cérémonie en grande pompe ont boycotté
par le patriarche de l'église orthodoxe
gilles rabin france brille c'est nicolas
ii a été enterré avec son sabre comme
tous les empereurs de russie au moment
où sont ensevelis enfin des restes du
dernier tsar assassiné avec sa famille
par les bolcheviks le 17 juillet 1918 80
n'est plus tôt jour pour jour le canon
tonne et une page de l'histoire russe se
tourne une page tragique et simplement
le pays doit répondre de ses actes même
après tant d'années elle aurait voulu
assister à la cérémonie mais les gens du
peuple n'était pas admis par la chapelle
il ne reste plus que la famille les
romanov un cesse des grands ducs les
grandes la russie d'aujourd'hui ont
presque tous refusé de participer sauf
le premier d'entre eux boris eltsine
venu dire que l'assassinât des romanov
était un crime dont était capable non
seulement les assassins mais aussi tous
ceux qui pendant huit décennies de
communisme ont approuvé justifier ce
crime est coupable nous sommes tous
à la fin du siècle le plus sanglant de
l'histoire de la russie boris eltsine
est en quelque sorte venu demander le
pardon des romanov pour qu'un peuple
russe réconcilier puisse entrer dans le
troisième millénaire
ça devait être aussi ça a été dit
maintenant oublier tout ça regarder vers
l'avenir
le chef de la maison romanov et si
heureux qu'ils acceptent de signer des
autographes
ils sont tous très beaux saint
pétersbourg découvre ce qui sans la
révolution d'octobre auraient été ses
princes et que des romanov sont restés
en russie sous de faux noms
boris eltsine je l' ai toujours aimé et
je l'estimais encore plus
ce commandement sera aussi présente
la russie découvre enfin que les plus
jeunes des romanov revenus d'exil n'ont
presque plus rien de russe au deuxième
jour de la visite du président syrien
paris hafez el-assad a assuré qu'il
ferait examiner la demande française
concernant aloïs brunner criminel nazi
soupçonné de vivre sous un faux nom en
syrie jacques chirac est revenu sur
cette question demandant une réponse
précise par ailleurs aujourd'hui au
centre des discussions officielles la
volonté de sauver le processus de paix
au proche-orient philippe rochot chat
gris barre
cette rencontre avec lionel jospin
marque la fin des entretiens politiques
d'hafez al assad à paris et le président
syrien a peut être satisfait du soutien
de la france
hier c'était jacques chirac qui plaidait
pour le retour du plateau du golan à la
syrie pendant le dîner de gala de
l'elysée aujourd'hui c'est le premier
ministre lionel jospin qui appuie les
revendications de damas comme l'ensemble
de la communauté internationale la
france reconnaît le droit de la syrie de
se voir restaurer sa souveraineté pleine
et entière sur le golan hafez el-assad a
confié à lionel jospin que pour lui
israël avait cassé les règles du jeu
après l'arrivée de netanyahou au pouvoir
alors que les pourparlers sur un retrait
du goal en étaient avancés avec le
gouvernement travailliste
auparavant hafez el-assad avait de
nouveau rencontré jacques chirac la
france poussent à la reprise des
négociations avec l'idée franco
égyptienne d'une rencontre des pays qui
veulent sauver la paix hafez el-assad
est prêt à s'y rallier
il estime que la france fait de sérieux
efforts et que si une action pacifique
est lancé on peut compter sur la syrie
à condition qu à la clé il y est le
retour du goal ans à la mère patrie mais
hafez el-assad c'est que benyamin
nétanyahou ne va pas renoncer au goal en
annexe et d'ailleurs par israël
assad a parlé à jacques chirac du risque
de l'engrenage d'une nouvelle guerre la
relance du processus de paix sera de
nouveau à l'ordre du jour mardi avec
l'arrivée à paris du roi hussein de
jordanie le premier ministre israélien
benjamin netanyahu vient de déclarer
qu'un accord sur le redéploiement
israéliens en cisjordanie était à portée
de main cette déclaration intervient
alors que le processus de paix au proche
orient connaît sa crise la plus grave
sur le terrain maintenant dans le sud de
la bande de gaza la coopération
militaire entre israéliens et
palestiniens se poursuit pourtant k 1 k
charles enderlin et alain grego on
signait une patrouille conjointe ça
les officiers de l'anp veulent pas
normalement les deux véhicules de la
patrouille conjointe doit peut-être l'un
à côté de l'autre
les palestiniens ont vu la caméra et
viennent se garer près de la gippe
israélienne ce n'est pas le grand amour
les israéliens ne veulent pas être filmé
ses patrouilles
un des derniers vestiges de la
coopération israélo palestiniennes se
poursuivent dans le secteur le plus
tendu de la bande de gaza il ya quinze
jours les deux camps étaient au bord de
l'affrontement armé
les israéliens avaient fermé une route
et en représailles les palestiniens
avaient bloqué tous les accès aux
implantations juives
enclavée dans les territoires autonomes
à gaza
le drame a été évité de justesse mais
les problèmes ne sont pas réglés
à gaza un million de palestiniens vivent
sur 200 kilomètres carrés alors que six
mille colons juifs occupent le reste 100
km² exemple de problème
voici la route vers les implantations
voyez comme elle est large
seuls les colons le droit de l'emprunter
les palestiniens non ce qui est
contraire aux accords de paix sur cette
route minuscule il est très difficile de
faire passer des camions
une situation qui suscite la colère de
la population palestinienne
tout finira par exploser ici ce sera
pire cavendish farrar la situation est
mauvaise les accords d'oslo c'était pour
les israéliens
en fait il n'y a pas d'appel au poste de
coordination conjoint l'officier
israélien des primes est la base de tout
accord pour c'est la confiance
or ici elle a disparu à cause des
derniers incidents violents le colonel
palestinien n'est pas plus optimiste
j'espère que nous parviendrons à
appliquer avec les israéliens les
accords signés à oslo et au caire et
sinon comme l'a dit mon président tout
est possible
pour tenter de faire baisser la tension
les israéliens ont invité leurs
partenaires palestiniens à partager un
repas sans le dire devant la caméra
ces militaires espèrent qu'ils ne
devront pas un jour à nouveau ce combat
retour en france les tricolores les uns
après les autres rentrent à la maison
aujourd'hui c'était au tour du capitaine
de l'équipe didier deschamps
entouré de son épouse et de son père
didier deschamps a redit son besoin de
décompresser à bayonne david bizier une
coupe du monde c'est une fièvre qui n'en
finit pas de retomber car décidément le
capitaine bayonnais de l'équipe de
france avait bien plus que 22 joueurs
sélectionnés derrière lui
des autographes toujours des autographes
car à bayonne la température ne
redescendra jamais elle vient de loin du
temps où didier deschamps jouer en
benjamins au club local de l'aviron
bayonnais
un an après avoir signé sa licence à
l'aviron bayonnais en tant que benjamin
il est jeune et il a été surclassé je
l'avait surclassé pour qu'il y ait la
minime soit minul et quelque chose qui
restera toujours c'est la facilité qu'il
avait à dépasser les autres au point de
vue physique que prévu vaillance il en
voulait toujours plus il aimait toujours
gagner et on voit que ses qualités n'ont
pas changé
les souvenirs qui date de presque 20 ans
mais pour didier deschamps l'hommage de
bayonne ferait presque oublier paris
c'est celui de ma région dans si c'est
lui je suis né où j'ai toute ma famille
mes amis dans celle des mariages qui me
touche beaucoup parce que c'est beaucoup
plus beau que tout ce que j'ai vécu
avant évidemment et bientôt quand le
petit deschamps saura lire il pourra
avoir une plaque sur le terrain de foot
de la ville rebaptisée aujourd'hui stade
didier deschamps
et puis mes jacques a été nommé
aujourd'hui directeur technique national
du football français son contrat de
sélectionneur national expire à la fin
du mois aimé jacquet succède donc à
gérard houllier dans le départ à 10
heures poules a été confirmée à la
rochelle les 14e francofolies ce qu'ils
prendront fin demain avec en invité
vedette gignac l'air à côté des grands
noms de la chanson française comme
michel sardou bernard lavilliers que
nous retrouvons dans un instant il est
aussi une génération de nouveaux
artistes portraits croisés de matthieu
chedid et de sinclair éric perrin
christophe vignal
non sinclair prénom sinclair définition
de votre style musical compliqué ça
c'est une sorte de chanson française
internationale
voyez ce que je veux dire non chedid
prénom mathieu nom de scène m6 music and
chanson française
question de génération il aime autant
gainsbourg et nougaro que prince et
stevie wonder sur leur musique sans
frontières des textes en français
sinclair et m revendique bien une
appartenance à la chanson d'aujourd'hui
deux artistes complets touchant à tous
les instruments deux auteurs
compositeurs interprètes amoureux de la
scène
l'antre nous deux
tha
veilleux
j'ai vraiment l'impression de faire
partie d'une génération tout comme
mathieu qui fait des choses lui un peu
un peu différente mais on fait partie
sur le truc un peu décalé
japd pour la
on aime le rapport avec les gens et puis
d'abord un du retour et de donner aux
gens une générosité je commençais
nouvelle génération ils sont doués
inventif leur spectacle est total
m sinclair une nouvelle génération qu'on
aime c'est clair
et nous retrouvons maintenant en direct
de la rochelle bernard lavilliers à
quelques minutes de son entrée en scène
et vous êtes au côté d'eric perd un bon
soir béatrice alors vous êtes là au
coeur de l'événement sur la grande scène
des francofolies de la rochelle qu'a
commencé vos dires tout doucettement
petite cuillère soir à retrouver son
public et ce soir un nouveau une grande
affiche avec bar en vedette bernard
lavilliers bernard bonjour
première question francofolies oblige on
connaît beaucoup pour la musique
latino-américaine également des grands
artistes comme léo ferré chanson
française chanson francophone ça
signifie vraiment quelque chose
1 toute façon c'est de la chanson
française je veux dire il ya vu une race
de chanson française populaire dont piaf
a été une des grandes représentantes
et puis il ya de la chanson en français
c'est à dire comme les autres la deûle
autre génération que j'aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs chedid et sinclair ils
mettent des mots en français sur des
rythmiques jazz jazz rock ou acid jazz
ou du hip hop
en tout cas ils utilisent des mots
française qui a toujours été une
difficulté par rapport aux rythmiques
assez swinguer en l'air qu'avec avait
d'autres comme il atteint donc on s'est
toujours débrouillé pour arriver enfin
nous à mettre des mots en français sur
des musiques comme les bois exotiques
qui était venu pour ça justement musique
exotique on peut pas vous présenter un
extrait du concert de bernard ce qui n'a
pas encore joué mais je crois qu'il veut
nous faire un petit cadeau spécialement
porno avec une version acoustique
alors c'est une des premières chansons
que j'ai dû chanter ici ça fait quand
même un moment que je le ferai quand je
veux dire aussi francofolies pour deux
raisons de toute façon quand je viens
ici il ya oussalé qu'on n'est pas seuls
et techniciens des musiciens avant tout
ça c'est pas nous qui le menton et je
rencontre toute la famille c'est à dire
qu'il n'ya pas que le fait de venir
chanter devant le public ya le public
mais il ya aussi tout un tas de copains
que j'ai pas vu depuis depuis ados trois
ans et c'est vraiment ça les
francofolies c'est à dire la réunion des
gens de la route apport et pour les
impatients mais pour cela allez vous
faire
viens petite soeur aux blancs manteaux
c'est la balado détrempée ya beaucoup de
rigueur l'une des bougies hier c'est la
descente au fond de la mine
il ya en gros shoots et du désespoir et
l'ont visitée mais laminoir même si
moche et méchant
merci bernard pour ce petit cadeau et
puis bah pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas la
chance d'être là ce soir et qui n'ont
pas pu suivre les francofolies sachez
que vous retrouvez les meilleurs moments
des francofolies sur france 2 le 29
juillet merci merci à bernard lavilliers
musique encore mais celle ci est plus
déroutantes
il s'agit d'un concert urbain symphonie
écrite à partir des bruits de la ville
par le concert d'allégro barbaro que
nous font découvrir car l'une laudrin
jean-louis melun ils sont tous musiciens
ils font tous partie de l'orchestré
d'allégro barbaro à leur tête pierre
sauvageot un compositeur un chef
d'orchestre vraiment pas comme les
autres il dirige sans baguette plutôt
avec les doigts avant d'écrire cette
création il s'était inspiré de marseille
une ville animée même bruyante
oui je passais beaucoup de temps à
écouter par exemple si beaucoup balade
dans les rues la nuit là jour et cetera
à écouter puis commencer à noter les
claques sont les sirènes les voitures
qui passaient les mobiles est dramatique
mobile avec tout ça on peut faire de la
musique le spectacle de pierre sauvageot
débute ainsi un homme seul face aux
spectateurs
ce registre ensuite les musiciens une
centaine tous des amateurs mais le vol
recrutés par annonce la cacophonie
s'organisent les bruits s'harmonisent et
en avant la musique
mais dans ce genre d'orchestre on n'est
jamais à l'abri d'un instrument
défaillant un pot d'échappement qui pète
un klaxon qui s'enraye
on s'est régalé c'est original
la colonie humaine et phonique
la prochaine fois que vous serez agressé
par le bruit d'une alarme ou d'une
mobylette dites vous que cette
cacophonie là n'est pas perdu pour tout
le monde
coup d'envoi des collections haute
couture demain en avant-première
portrait d'une mannequin qui débuta il
ya tout juste trente ans chez ungaro et
qui est devenue directrice de la haute
couture nicole cornu langlois et bernard
connor ont assisté en sa compagnie aux
répétitions dans les salons d'une gare
aux dernières retouches
dernière répétition pour une collection
toute en tendresse
accompagnés par la directrice de la
haute couture emanuel ungaro travaille
toujours en musique
il peut apprendre d'un mannequin se
perfectionner ou rectifier l'ordre de
passage des modèles pour le défilé
toujours en complicité avec catherine de
limur qui débute à elle-même comme
mannequin en juillet 1968
voici déjà 30 ans
elle devint d'abord directrice de la
boutique avant d'arriver à la haute
couture la couture c'est plus c'est plus
est plus feutrée et c'est plus
confidentielles ces fûts des rapports
plus humain parce que la femme bien
france on en bave à d'emprunter pas fini
voilà reçoit leurs attaches comme à la
maison à 18 ans cordelia de castellane a
la chance de choisir ses robes pour
l'été en couture d'un autre genre oui ça
coûte n'est pas morte est encore toute
une génération qui en moins d'un an
je vous dis pas que j'en ai toute une
soirée là dessus je préfère vraiment mes
baskets
j'essaie de les conseiller dans leurs
choix
je suis très souvent aussi des
hauts-de-seine partie passionnante parce
que là vous voyez vraiment l'élaboration
complet dit nous sommes la toile le sco
modèle fini c'est formidable
il lui arrive souvent de tôle exagère
mais c'est son rôle de toi exagère et de
tempérer cette sorte d'impulsion de
sauvagerie qui quelquefois mais prend
encore aujourd'hui malgré ces tant
d'années de travail
en voyant cette collection de
transparence argenté ou doré qui
allongent la silhouette catherine de
limur pense déjà aux clients du
privilégiés qui les porteront si elles
suivent bien ses conseils
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres laurent
fabius georgina dufoix edmond hervé
renvoyé devant la cour de justice pour
homicide involontaire dans l' affaire du
sang contaminé
puis le médecin de festina eric ricker
qui vient d'être mis en examen et écroué
le directeur sportif bruno roussel
également et nous rejoignant pour un
dernier point parce qu'elle le doubs
c'est bon en direct de lille pascal oui
béatrice comme vous allez le voir sur
les quelques images que nous avons
enregistré à l'instant bruno roussel a
été transférés vers une prison où il
passera la nuit tout comme le docteur
éric ryckaert le juge a pris cette
décision de mise en détention provisoire
pour éviter les ententes illicites et
les pressions c'est une décision assez
logique
à l'instant le procureur de la
république de lille nous a annoncé que
les coureurs eux pourront terminer le
tour de france ils ne seront entendus
comme témoins qu'à l'issue de la
compétition
enfin la confrontation entre willy voûte
bruno roussel et le docteur écarte
n'aura lieu que la semaine prochaine
le 24 juillet les deux amants tout cas
semble reconnaître le dopage de certains
des coureurs
ils ont avoué semble-t-il à la fin de
leur garde à vue
le dopage de leurs coureurs sous
contrôle médical précise-t-il
ils devront expliquer un peu plus aux
juges ce qu'ils entendent par là
ils prétendent que la vie des coureurs
n'étaient jamais en danger merci parce
qu'elle nous c'est bon pour ce dernier
point à 6 termine cette édition tout de
suite la météo de laurent romejko puis
le point route avec valérie maurice je
vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
d